[Music]
have you been doing some unusual stuff
around the home recently
you know little odd jobs maybe some new
challenges
in general just making a huge huge deal
out of things which shouldn't take you
any time at all
if you're anything like me the answer is
yes
but don't worry we are not alone
compared to this time last year uk sales
of baking ingredients
are up 63 diy supplies are up 64
and gardening products like bulbs and
seeds are up 132 percent
home improvement might seem like an
obvious choice while most of us are
stuck inside
but as my own to-do list became
increasingly random
i started to question my need to get on
with tasks
so i decided to talk to a psychologist
about it
in the last week or two it kind of feels
like i'm just trying to find
things to keep my hands busy in a way
and
it's that sort of normal behavior
in times of crisis it's what keeps us
going activity is what keeps us going
and
if you're somebody who is used to
working and being active
and then suddenly finding that a lot of
your normal structure and routine
is taken away or feeling very different
then it's absolutely natural that you
would
seek to reconstruct some kind of
routine into your day-to-day life
i know that a lot of people have been
doing challenges on social media
board game sales have gone through the
roof lots of people i've been talking to
though have been
turning to diy is it an element of
trying to sort of control the
environment as well perhaps
well at the moment with so much being
outside of our control
it really makes sense to focus on the
things
that we can control many people would
probably
um place a level of importance on their
home
so to invest something in developing
that space that carries meaning for us
and then it tends to make us feel better
and add more richness to our lives
i've been telling people on the video
team at the ft
about some of the things i've been doing
and um
yeah there's there's a fair bit of eye
rolling sometimes
um a lot of them have young kids
so i'm sure that home improvements and
things like that are kind of
quite far from their thoughts right now
is there a certain type of person who's
looking for these
little victories in a way it doesn't
matter so much what the activity is or
what the behavior is what matters is
that it is connected to a sense of
enjoyment or accomplishment
and that that is reflected by our wider
value system
and that doesn't mean that it has to be
a sort of massive
and impressive domestic and
transformation or anything like that
for some of us that just means keeping
going
through all of this keeping the
household together keeping everybody
safe and well it sounds like we
are we've all got different ways of
going about it but everyone i suppose is
trying to
come to terms with the new situation do
you have a message for people who
are feeling anxious and maybe a bit
uncertain
right now people are dealing with
the uncertainty that's going on the
threat of illness
the reality of illness loss in many
cases
i would say any behavioral response
anything that you
find that if you do it you feel a little
bit better
it's probably a helpful thing to do but
i would emphasize certainly not to
expect that to look the same
for um for any one of us because this is
a very unusual situation that we're in
dr alan i
couldn't agree more with you on that and
um i i feel
a bit vindicated then for for the things
i've been doing amongst
all my peers who've just got so much on
right now i'm a little worried actually
about running out of things to do now
um so the main thing that's been
the most difficult to to capture on
video for me has been
trying to sort of map the sleeping
habits of my cat he's not
playing ball so i think even if we're in
lockdown for another
month or more um that'll still offer
some challenges i'm sure having a cat
always helps i find
yeah he's he's he's around somewhere as
well he's a trickster
um well great thank you so much you too
take care james cheers bye
[Music]
bye